this video is brought to you by nano
creators of virtual reality tools for
immersive molecular visualization and
interaction follow the link in the video
description to download nano man explore
molecules yourself
since we're talking about proteins that
I want to mention something that's sort
of clinically related prions so what are
prions prions are basically just
infectious proteins sometimes they're
called infectious protein particles same
thing what's the deal with them
well they cause transmissible spongiform
encephalopathies or tses these things
are uncurable and they are 100% fatal so
they're pretty pretty brutal okay
some examples of transmissible
spongiform encephalopathies that are
caused by prions are kruetzfeldt Jakob
disease or CJD and there's some
different versions of that that affects
humans and kuru also affects humans so
those are obviously the more important
ones medically but it's also bovine
spongiform encephalopathy or BSE
popularly known as mad cow disease which
of course infects cattle and in their
scrapy which affects sheep and the deal
with prions is that they induce a change
to the secondary structure to otherwise
normal proteins by just simply
contacting those normal proteins and
they're pretty horrendous horrendous
diseases I mean I mentioned there in
career gold one hundred percent fatal
fatal but let's talk a little bit more
about prions so there's a protein called
prion protein which is a a normal
protein in our brain and other neural
tissues and this is kind of my
representation of it okay the key thing
there's is that it's it's designated PRP
or PRP C and that just stands for prion
protein and it's normal like I said as a
normal protein that exists in our in our
brain and other neural tissues and it
has a bunch of alpha helixes okay I've
got a bunch of alpha helixes
now there's another version of PRP which
is called prpsc and I think the SC
stands for or comes from scrapie which
is the disease in sheep caused by the
prion protein and there's this this
prpsc is the infectious prion protein
and it instead of having a bunch of
alpha helix it has a bunch of beta
pleated sheets and because of that the
beta pleated sheets are hard to degrade
this prpsc is very very stable and it's
resistant to degradation or denaturation
here's a quick 3d visual of the two
different prion proteins over here to
the left is the normal whoops
normal prion protein PRP and you can see
the bulk of it is made up of alpha helix
C's okay
the infectious prion protein however
prpsc over here you'll notice that the
bulk of it is made up of beta pleated
sheets right so this thing is
particularly stable because of those
beta pleated sheets and that is really
why it's a tremendous problem because
it's so resistant to degradation okay
and this protein when it comes into
contact with normal PRP right normal
prion proteins it turns those normal
prion proteins into an infectious prion
proteins and they go through and infect
more normal plant proteins and so it's
just pretty much exponential once it's
got ahold of normal prion proteins the
reason why this thing is is so so bad as
well is that it forms amyloid fibrils in
neural cells and it damages neural cells
and ends up killing those neural cells
and so it causes these transmissible
spongiform encephalopathies so these are
diseases of the brain and nervous
tissues in fact the spongy form refers
to the fact that it basically turns like
your brain to looking like a sponge
right it puts a bunch of holes in your
brain
because all those nervous cells end up
being damaged and they die and it's
actually pretty horrible what it does
and so and of course transmissible
refers to how infectious does PRP SC
version is and so some of the symptoms
are of course because it affects the
nervous system are as follows
memory loss involuntary muscular
movements seizures personality changes
balance and coordination problems
hallucinations speech impairment
paranoia all these different things as
far as the nervous system goes so and of
course without your brain and other
neural tissues you can't survive so and
it since there's no way to really undo
this at least not that I know of not
that I think scientists know of yet they
haven't figured out a way to kind of get
rid of or or solved this problem of
plant infections which is why the mad
cow disease whole thing was like
particularly scary to a lot of people
but yeah so I hope that video was
helpful and an interesting clinical
correlation to proteins thanks for
watching